Hey Youtubers it's Charlie, this is going
to be my Pixar inside out review in case you
guys haven't seen it what I'm going to do
is the first half of the video will be non-spoilery
and then the second half I'll do spoilers
so here we go one of the things I love most
about Pixar films is that they're not afraid
to try new ideas in this is like one of the
newest weirdest ideas that they've had for
movie most of the voice cast you'll probably
recognize the main cast is really the five
different emotions Joy's sadness discussed
anger and fear most the trailers feature any
polar she's to pretty much like the point
girl in the movie but the film is built around
all five emotions on one level it's a lot
like the toy story films and in that it's
about learning that it's okay for things to
change as you grow up but on a deeper level
this movie is a lot more about learning and
development and how that changes as you grow
up so is taking a much more internalized you
growing up thematically I mean if you're gonna
ties to a franchise though I would tie to
toy story because Pete Docter the director
also wrote inside out he's the same guy that
wrote all the toy story films oration say
that he wrote the original story that the
toy story movies are based on there's a difference
between the story in the screenplay it means
it's a bunch of different things but creatively
the toy story franchise in inside all flow
from the same place so if you like toy story
you like this is much more cerebral in the
sense that it focuses much more on the action
inside your head then on big the of the physical
actions you take in the real world so it's
almost literally reflexive in a way that the
toy story movies are at the toys and toy story
think about their own existence as toys which
is kind of funny and ironic the same time
the movie does try really hard to explain
the feedback loop of you know actions leading
to a emotions leading to long-term memories
and those memories influencing future actions
and even though so heavy on emotions I didn't
find it too emotionally manipulative this
is and game of thrones with memories there
has been a lot of talk about how the film
portrays depression because that's a big arc
in the film the proposition you begin with
is that the joy is like the most pure great
emotion you can feel and depression and sadness
is the opposite of that that's why you see
Amy Poehler and Phyllis Smith so much in the
trailer sadness is one of those actresses
that you know you've heard before but you
just can't place them she played Phyllis on
the office without getting too heavy to the
story the film does do a good job of of explaining
the relationship between these two seemingly
polar opposite emotions the real awareness
the film comes from some of the really big
things that it's missing actually think that's
a good thing I should think you awareness
and that it's good weird typically most stories
involving antagonist and protagonist this
film is not like that so it might seem a little
bit weird in that the there's no like big
villain to defeat a really good contrast this
is avengers age of all Tron they dated sequences
where you go inside the avengers minds and
that the deal with these really strange pseudo-memories
it's very weird and unexpected in the movie
where you expect a lot of punching and kicking
and even though that's not really what Pixar
films are about that there is a lot like punching
and kicking going on inside the toy story
films that there is a villain inside toy story
three trying to hurt the good toys and that's
not really how the narrative in inside-out
is constructed and I did as a really good
thing this is the kind of film that you might
end up watching inside like a high school
psychology class or like an intro college
class meet a lot of it's very whimsical but
a lot of the ideas are solid that the way
that memories are stored away memories change
on all give the movie a giant thumbs-up to
me you don't need to see it in 3-D your IMAX
or anything like that it totally works just
it and regular 2-D and a lot of my extra praise
for the film goes in the fact that Pixar was
willing to try something this weird that she
give you a lot of hope for the other big franchises
the Disney like Marvel and Star Wars I meet
you a lot of it is like recycling franchises
but then every once in a while they slip in
a film like this something that just so weird
and different that it feels like it doesn't
fit right away really where it starts to fit
is when you think of Pixar films in the context
of of what it's like to be a child can grow
up that mean that's really what those films
are about but just to get into spoilers on
to talk about a couple my favorite moments
in the film so careful if you haven't seen
the movie yet here we go far and away my favorite
part of the film was when they make it to
imagination land they run into Bing Bong,
he's played by Richard kind he is the perfect
voice of an imaginary friend just the right
amount of crazy energy like oh my God he's
a lunatic but this seems like it might be
fun it also doesn't hurt that he cries candy
I honestly I'd I don't think a lot of the
emotional arc of the film would've worked
without his sacrifice he in a way is like
one of the smartest characters in the film
because he comes to terms with his own existence
in the way that Riley like the little girl
hasn't yet to be fair though you don't really
expect a little kid to figure that out when
she has even hit puberty yet the puberty console
was a nice and tag like only got one with
this big red button does for the most part
like the other emotions besides joy and sadness
that are fairly forgettable I mean you know
Bill Hader Lewis Black Mindy Kaling they're
all great actors but they didn't really become
interesting till that and tag to you know
we started to see the the blended emotions
like fear and joy at the same time even though
it's an overly simplistic way to view emotions
that I thought it worked the film just says
emotions are extremely complex you can feel
a number of them in the same instance of if
you really want to get scientific about it
there a lot of biochemical processes associated
with forming memories and learning and development
that they did, left out it's almost like the
whole film is taking place inside the room
of abstract thought because it's presenting
these emotions is distinct things in an abstract
way so I guess that's probably the best way
to think about it that's an even better way
of describing the process by which I make
videos like I feel like I'm sitting inside
a room of abstract thought it feels completely
weird until I turn around and start editing
the video but here's my big question for you
guys what was your favorite part of the film
and do you want to see them try more weird
ideas like this that is to say films that
don't necessarily have a main villain to overcome
and resolutions that are kind of ambiguous
like all life is going to be complicated and
I'll deal with it as opposed to say like our
Marvel movie were it's like I punch you your
dead eye when Bam movie over for those you
asking like what Pixar movies are coming out
next so the good dinosaur is there next movie
that's coming this November it's it's like
the alternate history tell about like what
happens if the earth didn't get hit by giant
meteorite then there's finding Dori that's
like the next finding Nemo movie part of that
franchise so expect a lot of those actors
come back that's next year then toy story
for so you a couple franchise movies back
to back there is an incredible to I have yet
to meet a person that did not like that film
it did a great job of deconstructing the superhero
genre I don't know how they're going to fall
that up so we'll see expectations typically
get lowered for sequels really I think that
were waiting for is a really bad ass Pixar
Marvel collaboration on animated movie they
do a big heroes six but that's really like
a Disney animation Marvel collaboration and
that feels much more like a Disney film that
it does like a Marvel film the closest thing
we have to that is is the incredible franchise
in toy story they're both really good but
I feel like it it be really awesome to see
Marvel characters go through some sort of
story arc like you see in those films what
does it mean to be a superhero but we need
an inside out for Tony Stark that would be
a nightmare the whole movie would be that
giant clown from the subconscious stomping
around with the liquor bottle trying to chase
you so moving down the line Ant Man and fantastic
four, couple of other big movies coming this
summer that I'll be doing videos for,
sure to subscribe to get them is a the movies
the want me to do videos for just let me know
on the comments but white is way for that
you can click here for my Jurassic world review
probably one of the better films in the summer
it's a lot of fun maybe not quite as good as
Mad Max but you can click here to learn all about
some of the cast members the game of thrones
season six is looking for right now thank
you so much for watching, everybody let's
high five and I'll see you guys tonight!